[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مره على الجزيره العربيه عصور
متناطحه عصر التجمد وعصر السافانا وعصر
الامطار الموسميه وعصر التصحر ففي العصور
المطيره تخلقت اعداد لا متناهيه من
الشغايه والشعاب والاوديه والتي كانت
انهار جاريه في وادي الرمه يصب بشط العرب
ووادي حنيفه يصب الخليج العربي وفي العصر
التصحر تحولت الى مجاريه خامده تنهض في
الحالات المطريه بعضها ينهض في كل سنه
وبعضها ينهض كل 11 سنه والبعض الاخر ينهض
كل 70 سنه تبعا لدوره المطر التقريبيه بين
المطر والارض عشقوا سواليف فاضت من اشواقه
وعيون
السحابه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واغلب الاوديه تنتهي في بحار اوديه سلطنه
عمان واليمن ومرتفعات الحجاز ومرتفعات
عسير والبعض ينتهي في قاع محاط بالمرتفعات
من كل جوانب واذا فاضل معنا سميت فيضه
فيضه نوره فيضه الخفس فيضه التنهات وفياض
الاحترام وكذلك فياض الحاره واذا نشف
الماء وتبخر عنه وطلع الربيع سميناه روضه
احبك حبا لو يفيض يسيره على الناس مات
الناس من شده الحب
[موسيقى]